la renuncia del primer ministro
tailandés es una de las principales
exigencias de los ciudadanos que siguen
desafiando las prohibiciones y tomándose
las calles de bangkok piden también una
reducción del poder de la monarquía y
una nueva constitución sin embargo el
coni asegura que no se va e impuso la
prohibición de las reuniones de más de
cinco personas
el decreto de emergencia prohíbe las
reuniones y da autoridad para buscar y
detener a los sospechosos en el pasado
utilizábamos la ley normal para las
manifestaciones pero ahora estamos
aplicando la ley de situación de
emergencia y paul watson none the war
iii con my nails pese a las
prohibiciones decenas de miles
realizaron una de las mayores
manifestaciones el jueves por la noche
dos activistas fueron detenidos el
viernes y acusados de violencia en
contra de la reina esto después de que
levantaron tres dedos símbolo de las
peticiones de quienes protestan ante el
paso de la caravana de la reina a su
vida los acusados podrían llegar a
enfrentar la pena de muerte
se me acusa de haber intentado lastimar
a la reina y al potencial heredero del
trono después de que se emitiera el
decreto de emergencia los manifestantes
han denunciado el arresto de más de 20
activistas entre ellos varios líderes
del movimiento están planeando otra
masiva manifestación este viernes